IN THE MEANTIME, ASK THEM TO
CLEAN UP THE GRAFFITI ON LOCAL
FACILITIES.
WOW.
TONIGHT THE ACTING DHS
SECRETARY IS CONDEMNING THE
VIOLENCE, REFUSING TO STAND
DOWN.
HE JOINS US LIVE ON THE GROUND
IN PORTLAND.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I GUESS THE FIRST QUESTION IS,
OKAY, IN EVERY CASE WHERE THE
PRESIDENT HAS OFFERED AND GIVEN
HELP, MINNEAPOLIS, D.C. FOR
EXAMPLE, THINGS HAVE GOTTEN
UNDER CONTROL.
SEATTLE, WE HAD REPORTS AND THEN
CONFIRMED BY THE PRESIDENT, HE
SAID YEAH, WE SAID WE ARE GOING
TO GO IN, WHICH PRECIPITATED
FINALLY THE END OF THE CHOP ZONE
WHERE INNOCENT PEOPLE DIED.
NOW IT HAS HAPPENED IN OTHER
CITIES, YOU SEE THE VIOLENCE IN
CHICAGO, NEW YORK, OTHER PLACES,
SO NOW YOU ARE GOING TO GET
LECTURED BY A MAYOR WHO IS DOING
NOTHING TO STOP THE VIOLENCE OR
PROTECT BUSINESSES IN THAT CITY.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AND
THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT.
EARLIER THIS WEEK I CALLED NOT
ONLY THE MAYOR BUT THE GOVERNOR.
I OFFERED DHS SUPPORT TO HELP
THEM LOCALLY ADDRESS THE
SITUATION AND THEIR ONLY
RESPONSE WAS PLEASE PACK UP AND
GO HOME.
THAT IS JUST NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
ON MY WATCH SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE ARE SUPPORTING OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS HERE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE
COURTHOUSE.
THAT IS WHAT THE DHS DOES.
THAT IS OUR MISSION, WE ARE NOT
GOING TO ADVOCATE OUR MISSION,
RESPONSIBILITIES, HOWEVER WITH
THE LOCAL LEADERSHIP IS TELLING
US, WE’RE GOING TO DO OUR JOB,
WE ARE GOING TO DO IT
PROFESSIONALLY BUT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE THESE VIOLENT
ANARCHISTS WHO SHOW UP ABOUT THE
SAME TIME EVERY NIGHT FOR A
SERIES OF HOURS AND HAVING THAT
FEDERAL DESTRUCTION TO PROPERTY.
I WAS ABLE TO TOUR THE
COURTHOUSE, I SAW THE GRAFFITI,
THE BROKEN WINDOWS, THE BROKEN
DOORS.
THERE IS A FACILITY RIGHT ACROSS
THE STREET FROM THE COURTHOUSE
THAT HAS 47 COATS OF PAINT ON
IT.
YOU HAVE TO THE FACILITY EVERY
NIGHT AFTER HE GETS GRAFFITI.
IT’S TIME WE TAKE A STAND, IT’S
TIME THE LOCAL LEADERS HERE
PUBLICLY CONDEMN WITH THE
VIOLENT ANARCHISTS ARE DOING.
AND ONLY THEM I THINK WILL LOCAL
POLICE GET THIS UNDER CONTROL.
>> Sean: I’VE BEEN SAYING IF
YOU LIKE WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
SEATTLE, NEW YORK AND OTHER
PLACES, CITIES RUN BY LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES, THAT
WOULD BE A PREVIEW OF COMING
ATTRACTIONS IF JOE BIDEN IS
ELECTED.
I’M TRYING TO WRAP MY MIND
AROUND THIS, YOU’RE OFFERING TO
HELP CREATE SAFETY AND SECURITY
FOR THE PEOPLE OF PORTLAND.
THE PRESIDENT HAS OFFERED ALL OF
THESE CITIES.
NOW, HE CAN CONSTITUTIONALLY USE
THE 1807 INSURRECTION ACT BUT
THE PRESIDENT HAS ALSO SAID THAT
HE IS GOING TO GO IN AND HE IS
GOING TO RESTORE ORDER IN THESE
WAR ZONES.
WHAT WILL THAT ENTAIL?
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR APPARENTLY
VERY SOON.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND AGAIN, WE
CONTINUE TO OFFER THAT SUPPORT
SPECIFICALLY HERE IN PORTLAND,
WANTING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ENOUGH ASSETS, WHETHER IT’S
PERSONNEL, CAPABILITIES AND THAT
WAS MY DIRECT ASK AND OFFER TO
THE MAYOR AND AGAIN, THE ONLY
RESPONSE WAS PLEASE PACK UP AND
GO HOME.
AGAIN, I ASK THE MAYOR AND I ASK
OTHERS, WHAT DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO OCCUR?
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
COURTHOUSE, FEDERAL FACILITIES
OVERRUN BY THESE VIOLENT
ANARCHISTS.
WHAT I’M ASKING YOU, ALL STATE
AND LOCAL LEADERS HERE IN
PORTLAND, IN OREGON, IS COME OUT
SPECIFICALLY AND PUBLICLY
CONDEMN THESE VIOLENT
ANARCHISTS, BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU’RE CREATING AN ENVIRONMENT,
YOU ARE FOSTERING AN THAT
CONTINUES TO BREED THIS TYPE OF
LAWLESSNESS.
WE SELL THIS BACK IN 2018
UNFORTUNATELY HERE IN PORTLAND
WHERE THEY SET SIEGE TO A I.C.E.
FACILITY FOR OVER 28 DAYS.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF ENVIRONMENT
AGAIN THAT IS FOSTERED HERE.
WE’VE HAD ENOUGH OF IT, WE’RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROTECT THE
COURTHOUSE AND YOU ARE DO OUR MI
THE END OF THE DAY.
>> Sean: THAT IS MIND-NUMBING
TO ME, PROTECTING A BUSINESS,